[Music]
what's right to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
history is gonna change
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
deep
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
there it is more they a little extra
something in there because our lovely PA
miss Dickinson today added in there it's
a movie reference you told me that now
after I have regular tap water well
that's what you get forces my hand
he's like Adam Smith it's the invisible
hand at the termination if the hand word
is hole Jerald a is here how are you sir
I am well
Topol is lahore a quarter black would
you say you were saying topo and so I
was going to say quarter but I said core
oh speaking until I get through this
quarter black Garrett is there and we
have a lot to get to today of course
subscribe on Crowder bits that's another
channel here on YouTube we're available
anywhere podcasts are available and of
course please do consider subscribing to
Mudd Club because we have less money
than ever on YouTube which is really
just zero yeah we have this same money
as ever in the last couple of years and
not all of this show is broadcast on
YouTube so after the first thing we go
exclusive to the Mudd Club
yeah really quickly let's check in with
CNN and Sideshow Bob but to step into a
rake and use them in a different way
they don't have the expertise to respond
to every social ill of society
homelessness substance use disorders in
blue this was something funny they just
saw they're talking about CNN earlier
this morning this you know home why
don't we defund the police and put some
of that money for example like they make
it a crime to be homeless put more money
into public housing public housing um
the projects more crime or less crime on
that well I think you burned down in
Minneapolis first stuff like on night
one oh yeah that's right affordable
housing and we are going to be doing a
rebuttal here too we haven't done one of
these in a while a full from stem to
stern rebuttal
on John Oliver his his anti police video
my questions why do you let me ask you
this why do you think today so many in
the news and often I'll say progressive
left but news I repeat myself why do you
think they can get away with these
unfounded claims when there is data
available specifically regarding the
police I think a lot of us would like to
find some common ground on fixing issues
with the police I've talked about police
unions for a very long time but that is
not what is being requested and the
requests are predicated on lies
absolutely and everybody believes them
everybody just runs with this
two-and-a-half times number and we'll
get to that in a little bit but it blows
my mind that nobody's challenged this
openly you don't hear it on CNN right
you don't hear that's four people and
you connect in Charlotte yeah well we've
got a cultural problem where when people
read a headline they don't check it out
right they're not gonna they're gonna go
in actual police statistics or let's
find out what the other side has to say
it is a cultural problems right just a
news problem I wasn't listening because
I was thinking about in Charlotte
Airport I have connected the problem Oh
jangles delicious people debate about
chicken Bojangles is wonderful the only
better bread chicken ever had was in Las
Vegas Nevada and it was a Filipino owned
gas station and I thought I was taking
my love with my hands yeah exactly go oh
it was an explosion in my mouth with
Escrima sticks art of stick fighting
there's such uncultured groups before we
get to before we get to a John Oliver by
the way this is in hearing that buzz in
my ear a little bit we have one XLR
there's so many cords one of them gives
you a buzz oh really
yeah thought I fixed it there's a few
consumers yes oh now you're in my line
of work that's a long way around for a
dad joke Gerald the old guy would be
pushed down by Donald not by down from
the old guy who was pushed down by the
believed yeah that's what happens David
what old guy pushes another old guy you
know yeah mr. Clyburn double per minute
push it push it good wish - I was just
looking up before we get to this the old
old guy who was shut down by police
officers and Donald trum tweeted about
it six nine this guy I started I just
went down to horrible we're not that
we're not the old people we go like this
is really bad like people would say to
us because we listened to you know punk
rock like auntie flaggers there was
still some semblance if there was a
bridge of musical connection yeah right
- now this six nine character is one of
the thinkers are you just looking for a
rhyme oh okay and when you just think
about how far we've gone to like every
one of these videos is just just it's
just asses and like it's women ain't
pressing their buttocks against a man's
crotch area no it's not culture be cut
up please just once for trade out let
them try to say something Joe just keeps
talking what is it you're saying I said
jeez okay it was supporting it for that
have you seen the crotch rubbing with
the butts no okay and bridge the
cultural divide I was do not want to
hear about crotch rubbing with butts
alright feels like a trick so no it's
not cultural you go back to the Beatles
and I want to hold you you can find in
any society you can go to Egyptian
hieroglyphics and see people holding
hands delight it's still about a lover
and wanting to engage in making love
with a lover globe in the booty a little
bit more modern remember how how
controversial salacious salt and pepper
were it was push it push it real good
now it's just rubbing my ass on your
crotch my neck
I'm like oh my god this is gonna be
someone's wedding song yeah dance floors
anyway so I don't get it
we do have a sponsor oh we do Oh before
we go what before we go to the ant 4
story let's go to a sponsor really
quickly who is it's uh oh that's your
new sponsor yeah oh yeah that's right
I'm thrilled of course blood sponsor 20%
off yeah our new sponsor is a morning
shower a morning shower a morning shower
is one of the best ways to reduce muscle
tension improve circulation and boost
your immune system it helps to reduce
stress removes toxins and has even been
shown to help treat depression that is
if you can get past the memories of that
scene from psycho showering daily helps
regulate sleep patterns improves lung
function and leaves your skin looking
beautiful beautiful like the young Lila
crane who leaves the big city after
stealing money from her workplace and
stops for the night at the Bates Motel
only to be brutally stabbed to death in
the shower by a shadowy figure as Lila's
blood circles the drain the audience is
left wondering who was the shadowy
figure how will the film proceed after
the death of the protagonist and will I
ever be able to shower again without
thinking of this horrific slaughter
regular showering is ideal for heart
health
soothes itchy skin and can even regulate
your core body temperature but not for
Lila poor poor Lila a morning shower
worth the risk by the way we can't
actually we can't confirm the veracity
of any those health claims that's my
primary concern that's what our recent
sponsor with your wife with the she's
fine chill she definitely understands
yeah your wife is pregnant my wife I
think we talked about this yesterday
well turns out after the show
it is GBS my wife is fine but I am oh I
would like now I have to crucify all of
you because I'd adopter come in and go
well listen who's the doctor here I
don't know [ __ ] because the other
doctor said
you don't know what you're talking about
it's confusing when they have different
points of view and they both claim to be
experts we all told me to tell you to
stop talking that's Joe that's right
it's primarily my primary my primarily
my gripe is due to the fact that I'm
anti science speaking of science gravity
Newton the old guy who was pushed at the
protest Donald Trump tweeted this out
that seemed like the old guy he was
saying could be and we there's no way to
necessarily confirm this the guy could
have been antiphon old man looking for
trying to actually obtain police scanner
information no idea not but it wouldn't
surprise me I was like he's Tom Cruise
they're looking around at the end of a
meeting like who we're gonna send in
there now you look like a criminal now
huh hey John my opinion changed in
real-time yeah I was watching like oh
that looks really bad because no man is
being pushed but then you go wait a
second he's walking up to a police
officer they said leave they shove him
and then he's reaching stopping short
reaching paged me for the hip where a
gun wasn't well I don't know how see
it's unfortunate that he fell of course
right we'd rather that not happen but
this is where we are now as a society
when you when you write and you loot and
people support that and say that
violence should play a role in protests
well guess what you're gonna get more
violence that's when you get the
military that's when you get the
National Guard I don't know how you
expected this to end
yeah people on edge this stuff happens
so let's go right now to John Oliver
speaking of what do you think about John
Oliver we were talking about this just
before the show do you
is he a smart guy that yeah I think it's
more is he just I think John Oliver is
smart I think he's very funny yeah I
think he's absolutely funny I do have a
bit of a different perspective America's
stupid Road you know but as a Canadian I
have a bit of a because we still have
the Queen in her money that's true we're
big fans of kneeling in Canada I've been
doing it for a very long time for in
session I have a different perspective
because I just think a lot of people
don't realize that someone like John
Oliver can be smart but he's smart
operating with the information that he
has there is no in Canada that really
what in Quebec there wasn't a real
Conservative Party would be basically
sort of a centrist Democrat with may be
pro-life leanings in Canada and you
might get that in Britain now it's
changed a bit with brexit but they do
have blind spots and it doesn't mean
they're dumb but he certainly is
misinformed because he's a German
inferior country he's yeah he seems like
he's Wilfred willfully ignorant of times
you say Wilfred well Murray is there
struggling yeah you see but he seems
very knowledgeable sometimes you're like
oh that's a great point and you're right
he is funny yeah and then other times he
says stuff and I'm like wait a minute
you sound like an idiot
like you sound like somebody who's never
looked into anything that you're talking
about well he doesn't he has 54
researchers and writers so you would so
it was 55 idiots a little less grace but
he did a whole video here on the police
and like always doesn't really call for
concrete solutions you know it's always
just bitching about what is wrong and
where the right is wrong it's a lot
easier to criticize without offering any
sort of constructive solutions than it
is to try and put in the legwork so um
that being said he gets so much of this
wrong I encourage you to go watch the
entire video I don't know if you can
pirate it like I used to with Michael
Moore films like no I want to see I spy
with Owen Wilson and Eddie Murphy no one
wants to see ya nobody saw they should
have known but you know the people at
the movie theater it was very night 9/11
you won't get a dime out of me because I
don't want it going to Enron one of your
investments Michael Moore let's start
this off with John Oliver and everything
wrong with his police bias anti police
video let's go in response to those
protests which have been a stirring
pushback against institutional racism
and brutality is been frankly sickening
to see them met with this across the
country peaceful protests have to often
devolved into standoffs with heavily
armed police using military style
tactics these same people who by the way
say military-style weapons late semi
automatic with fully automatic and bio
we need to be really we need to be
deliberate about this you know the
reason that police moved from say
revolvers to semi autos is because of
the 96 I think Miami shootout I don't
have a source for this but I believe was
FBI agents and two perps who had
committed many violent crimes they
killed two officers so eight of them and
they were outgunned 120 something rounds
were fired
Wow and they realized they were
outgunned by people on the street and
they didn't even have I don't believe
ar-15s they had two to threes and so
they said oh we can't have service
revolvers anymore because this is one
thing where you talk about using
military tactics against civilians are
the Crips and bloods just civilians are
the same umbrella
I think we sort of need the police force
to be adept and to be equipped I don't
mean that there should be this crazy
superpower like the American military
which I do support I like us being
number one there um because they need to
protect civilians if you will need to
protect civilians from people who have
military-style weapons and many of them
actually do you know if you go down to
the wrong area of Los Angeles they
absolutely fully automatic ak-47 well
that's the Koreans protecting their
businesses no no guns that are legal I'm
talking about people who illegally read
firearms in Los Angeles which really in
Los Angeles means anyone who owns
firearms so good point yeah that's like
a small arms race yeah they they get
armor-piercing they get guns they have
so it's you just keep going up and up
and do you notice there's no mention by
the way from John Oliver no mention at
all of any violence at the protest so
this sets a whole tone so you think wow
these are mostly peaceful protests no in
major cities all of them without
exception maybe now there might be two
exceptions I'm not talking about forty
people in some place in West Texas or 20
people in a separate post protesting
Hermosa Beach New York Los Angeles
Minneapolis Baltimore Detroit Dallas
take your pick the majority of them the
vast majority if not all once the lights
go out at night have resulted in violent
protests that is not mentioned during
this video or at least not really
touched upon considering it's 30
something minutes you're writing police
officers let me give you a couple
numbers in case you don't know 13 people
last week were killed from the right the
numbers now over 20 people 400 officers
injured I don't if at that point
officers don't have the right to respond
with riot gear then I guess just
completely disband the police yeah well
what do you think was happening in LA in
Chicago and New York when they met the
next morning after night one of the
protests guys here's the footage of what
happened
last night this is coming to a theater
near you we have to be ready right every
sing that the tone was set by the first
night of burning everything down and
looting you want to have a peaceful
protest you want to have peaceful
protests around the country don't start
off like that because the bins are
expecting it to turn yours you have to
send in the firefighters if you want to
remodel your home great but if it's on
fire send in the firefighters first
right now cities are on exactly we need
to be clear about that so we really need
to deal with the systemic discrimination
no we really need to deal with is
several dozen people being killed by
looters and rioters and foreigner
officers injured and the vast majority
of Americans 70 something percent
supporting the National Guard going in
because they're afraid in their own
cities so no no I get that you want
crown molding moving forward and that
would be nice right now I want to
prevent the house from setting the
neighbour's house ablaze let's go to the
next clip the protesters message has
taken many forms from chance to signs to
a man who called into an LA Police
Commission meeting held over zoo how
about shooting David Doran want to talk
about all of your forms that this
protest has taken it's like taking track
trakula can take many different forms a
human don't do that David Dorn patrick
underwood people who don't remember
these are officers black officers have
been killed and you can find more
footage than you could watch in the span
of this show yeah of black officers
being berated by privileged white
protests right and John Oliver doesn't
get to pick which of those is
representative they're both happening
and we can see videos of both of them
but has John Oliver seen these videos I
don't know I mean a lot of a lot of time
has been insulated from a lot of the
violence right yeah it's a tragedy well
later on in the video and this is one of
the segments that he just kind of
brushes over he's like and if you're
worried about any shows like a Macy's
stores boarded up he's like if you're
worried about this more than you're
worried about something else then then
you're wrong yeah he says something much
more vulgar than that like eff off right
so you definitely know you know he's
seen it and yes just saying that doesn't
matter and so your points very valid
right the house is burning down right
now what we have to do is make sure that
we save the house we might worry about
the furniture right now because you
burned down the furnace John Oliver's
house is pretty safe yeah yeah that's
true David hedges and gave these boys
violent
rioters and looters will be shocked to
find out you are not amongst them you
are a man of the people um yeah no
you're absolutely right you know what
let's go to the the next clip there's so
many from John Oliver in announcing job
numbers on Friday in votes George
Floyd's name saying this was a great day
for him which is utterly disgusting it
would be if that were true at all oh oh
wait I would agree
how many time to this show we said yeah
it runs an [ __ ] but our ass yeah they
said this must be a typo 300 jobs gained
gay people it's hilarious yes Larry I
agree with you but in this case that is
not what he was actually talking about
specifically people receiving equal
treatment under the law here's the
actual clip for context which generally
doesn't show you equal justice under the
law must mean that every American
receives equal treatment in every
encounter with law enforcement
regardless of race color gender a Creed
they have to receive fair treatment from
law enforcement they have to receive it
we also what happened last week we can't
let that happen
hopefully George is looking down right
now and saying this a great thing that's
happening for our country there's a
great day for him it's a great day for
everybody
now Wow sounds great not only does that
entirely change the context who who
would have thought let's say in the year
2008 that that would be a controversial
statement right yeah and remember we
were watching this drink Don Lemon all
said why can't our president let the
name of George Floyd leave his mouth he
just did it there that's why 25 percent
of his speech that day was devoted to
George Floyd we incident that happened
but we can't talk about a cover every
other Donald Trump tweet right yes
awesome video that he put out right yeah
it doesn't exist anymore all right I'm
trying to see what else we have from
John Oliver Oh oh yeah this next book
was great it didn't start this week all
with this president and it always
disproportionately for
on black communities because here are
some hard facts in Minneapolis where
George Floyd was murdered police use
force against black people at seven
times the rate of whites black Americans
are two-and-a-half times more likely
than whites to be killed by police and
about one in every thousand black men
can expect to be killed by police if
you're black in America I can't even
begin to imagine how scared angry and
exhausted you must feel my gosh um okay
let me ask you this what do you think
when you're talking about interactions
with police officers and this is all of
those numbers are accurate I want to be
clear the numbers that he cites but the
context does in context what do you
think should be the most relevant number
when talking about disproportional
violence committed against people of a
specific race in the United States
police interactions how many times do
you how often do you if it's 2.7 times
the amount of killings of black people
for the officers let's say in
Minneapolis or whatever the number is
that he says well on a second it matters
if they make up 10 to 15 percent of the
population and commit I have it right
here 53 percent of known homicide in the
United States sixty percent of robberies
but they're only 25 percent of those
killed by police so what doesn't matter
just what the percentage of the
population is black or white right
it doesn't just matter the numbers don't
exist in a vacuum it is how often are
these groups of people committing crimes
and again this is what we talked about
George Floyd versus David donor Patrick
underwood why does it matter it's not
just to go tit for tat hey black lives
matter black officer no it's because we
need to address the actual problems in
the community just like we need to
address the actual problems with police
defunding police won't work it's not
going to help I know you're trying to
shift the Overton Window but really
you're just somewhat you're just in rear
window looking for telescope going on I
don't have a dog in this fight yeah if
you fund the entire police is ever gonna
happen so and then the guy looks yeah
Raymond I got an erection so whoa really
no not for you
again please fatally shot nine unarmed
black men last year 2019 that was badass
tourney Obama years 19 unarmed whites
which really that's a startling
statistic when you consider how much of
the crime is made up by Black American
offenders and again this goes back to
the idea of we don't need police we mean
more public housing you can't find and
narrow do well in public housing or the
projects as it's been heard on every
single hiphop mixtape since 1994 right
there's where you go to get street cred
okay what a rich white record executive
says you're you're not hard enough let's
send you the projects on a weekend
anyway so I'll shoot you it'll go
straight through the cheek and you come
back in we make you look lean just fine
so we're having an emotional response
right now to this and that's
understandable right it's understandable
to be emotionally angry at stuff that's
happening in the world around you right
we don't need an emotional response when
we want to change things right we don't
want to respond emotionally because our
feelings are real but they're not always
reliable and right now they're not very
reliable saying get rid of the police
they're not very reliable when it says
two and a half times the number of black
people are shot by cops than white
people when that's a it's like it's like
saying that I'm still one of the top 1%
of tight ends in the nation that's true
if you take the entire population of
people and include people who don't play
football put me in the NFL where it
matters where the stat really matters
yeah I'm not in the top 1% okay that's
where it matters and that's what people
are doing right now and they're saying
of the entire population and they're not
taking try text anything else also um
again in the NFL if you were that you'd
beat you'd stick out like a very white
sore thumb no there's tons of white
tights like it's all right answers still
predominate I discern yes
not that I care it's just like if you
want to for some reasons I'm sorry
[Laughter]
there's a chair in the hall I'll never
win many studies have found by the way
we can bring this up that police are no
more likely to shoot black people than
white people now I and I hate the fact
that I have to say black white black
white right because this is the way it's
framed from the left and we'll go to
joob reason a little bit when you try to
make people feel ashamed exclusively
because of their race don't be surprised
when people all of a sudden take pride
in exclusively their race there will be
more racists created than ever in my
lifetime because you have asked white
people to kneel in subservience for a
crime they didn't commit this is why I
said weeks ago stop this please it's
going to get bad please stop this
there's a better way to go about it well
here we are and john oliver is leading
the charge from his penthouse of course
not actually done on the ground here's a
drone because let's go guys some of
America's first law enforcement units
were these slave patrols tossed with
capturing and returning people who'd
escaped from slavery and when slavery
ended what people had no intention of
letting that be the end of white power
the British colonial police force like
here any relation to slavery to
transition into of course so this is
indicative of systemic racism based on
systemic discrimination okay name a
single racist law today name a single
form of systemic oppression in this case
specific because it changes over those
transgenders rather than dumping target
right but today we've gone back to black
so name me one law that specifically
discriminates oppresses or targets black
individuals putting them at a systemic
disadvantage one one I can name several
the cave legs up to try and correct this
whether you talking about a permit of
action with you're talking about
diversity hires quotas which is
supported by everyone at the DNC name me
one that is pool dunking a black person
in 2020 stay down there because we had
slavery in police don't you know that
police were created to keep slaves in
this country what are you doing is that
what he really thinks is going on name
me one that's a challenge to anybody out
there yeah and if they could we could
target that we could fight that where
you go after that and get rid of that
policy they were maybe a racist wolf
yeah if you can name me a racist
politician or if you can name me race
cops if you can tell me people that you
can prove this person is targeting
people based on race we can deal with
that you know we can't deal with
systemic racism this ethereal concept
that the whole thing is rigged against
everything gets labeled that and the
whole concept of systemic racism removes
any personal responsibility from an
individual right so if you're if you're
down it's but it's not because you've
chosen to be down or even relatively
chosen to be down it's that you are
oppressed by this particular system or
now even it's gone further if you commit
a crime it's not really your fault right
carnation is because it's because the
system what but you burned a car
Toyota's [ __ ] yeah I don't own that
car we don't know nothing so we can burn
I tell you what I'll [ __ ] I'll share it
I'll get y'all cars y'all wanna talk I
gotta say what you want to target I'm
making a run oh yeah so and why if this
is all true why why is nobody talking
about married privilege right people who
are married tend to commit crimes at the
same level with what no matter their
color right right they tend to be
arrested at the same level them out of
their color right so yeah we should all
be talking about married what we shot
I'm having a privilege having a mom dad
privilege children yeah I just want to
apologize for my having a dad privilege
you know what that is something that I
do consider a privilege sure yeah I
don't consider I don't the term white
privilege is so loaded and by when we
talk about racism for the longest what
do we mean we meant vilifying penal or
condemning people exclusively because of
the race not seeing people as different
because of the race though at one point
that was considered racist because we're
all supposed to be colorblind now you're
not a good Ally if you're colorblind but
specifically in dieting someone based on
the color of their skin that's racist I
don't believe in reverse racism
I believe in racism period so let me ask
you this who is more racist the what any
of the white guys here quarter black guy
here in this room who's saying listen
name us a single racist policy that we
can fix so we can actually find out what
the problem is if it exists or the
person saying Neil white devil that is
textbook racism demanding that somebody
kneel me kneeling let's be clear is not
equality kneeling is subservient
kneeling specifically is absurd it means
without question it means giving
authority without question regardless of
the requests made that is why I will
[ __ ] I will listen I will discuss I will
hear your grievances I will never kneel
and I will never vote for a politician
who kneels that include Donald Trump or
Mike Pence if Donald Trump or my pants
take a knee I'm not voting for and the
people who are kneeling if you're a
black person making a white person no
the person the white person kneeling in
front of you is afraid of you right yeah
right is that what you is this the
relationship that you want right well
did you know that the easiest way to fix
racism is just to add more racism right
right and so it just it just helps right
I don't know why because we solve the
greatest evil of this country let's
bring in more black slave traders that
should even the playing it's called
ribbony the point is you need to have
for anyway the quality of our cats go
nice quick the major obstacles to reform
have been because one of the biggest
issues is police unions even in cities
where the mayor and police chief say all
the right things it's important to know
that the union can stop whatever they
are proposing dead in its tracks and
unions can make it incredibly difficult
to discipline officers even for
egregious misconduct take what happened
in Minneapolis with two officers who
belonged to our friend Bob's Union okay
Bob common ground solution so let me
I've said this many times yeah
dissolve police unions right now if
we're talking about complete abolition
of the police which a significant
portion of protesters are including the
protesters who operated the mayor let's
be clear some people are now trying to
sort of sugarcoat and say well we just
mean defund some portions of the police
for social workers which by the way I
would be on board with if I didn't know
that then you were going to demand
defunding all police but we should start
with that dissolve police unions and
then if we want a union build one up
with some some kind of accountability
now there's some common ground but John
Oliver has done segments on unions has
done segments on right-to-work states so
if we are trying to find a common ground
solution and we are considered radical
what right-wing extremist lemaster this
when I say dissolve police unions it is
100% consistent with my views on unions
across the board in every other sector
of life now when John Oliver says we
need to do something about police unions
it isn't I
an anomaly with his view of unions in
every other aspect of life so who is the
radical if the common ground solution
that we can find right now is consistent
with my view the all year long yeah I'm
glad he said it I'm just glad that he
acknowledged that these guys are part of
the problem guess what
hopefully you'll keep walking down the
road and see that most men II Democrats
do think it can evoke to dissolve police
unions and set that precedent right yeah
he keeps saying and I think he said in
this clip and I'm not sure he keeps
using the word we write as if we need to
be part of the solution who are you yeah
are some Brummie from England right what
do you but yeah does he think that he's
part of the problem I mean you know
Britain had had the slave trade to they
Britain abolish it before still this is
in the English Empire long after we
abolish labor that's one thing I don't
understand so people like families in
Canada it depends on when that happened
because in Canada oh great look more
slaves okay look over here and join your
slave they're the ones that sent out the
Flyers come to Canada you'll be free
yeah and as if he thinks that because
he's a white person living in America
that he was part of the problem and he
needs to be part of the solution he's an
Englishman yeah how is yes to me that is
so it's their protests in Paris and
London bread and Marcia said well second
are you saying that all of your police
forces are racist well let's discount
the French because they're just always
looking for a riot and there hasn't been
a soccer game because of the code so you
saying that your police force is racist
in which case it's not inherently unique
to American history or are you writing
and burning down your cities because you
have a problem with the Minneapolis
police force in which case you're just
looking for a reason to burn down cities
right there's no reason that people
should be writing anywhere in Europe
yeah if you've got a cinder block about
to throw it through a CVS or whatever
they have over there yeah then I thought
was a big Rite Aid the problem is not in
your system isn't you well the problems
in your head there we go yeah yeah you
you are the it is the cinder block
largely you can break cinder blocks
really easily especially if you're the
free break and
Bruce Lee his little demonstration oh
yes already pre crack that here use my
cinderblock
I don't want ok I understand it's so
such bullcrap i watch that 34 minute
listen bruce lee brilliant theorist
marshall on that one of course we've
talked about this but this idea of
breaking boards and syndrome no one is
going down to a construction site in
telling the foreman hey listen if you
need a hand I can one-inch punch now
it's it's a sure it's a charade they're
charlatans by the way hit the
notification bell hit all notifications
if you're watching on YouTube because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot new
videos go up every single day and of
course there's a livestream on Thursday
and do consider joining my club if you
enjoy this content because those who
support the paid content that's the only
reason that there's free content to
begin you get a wonderful hand etched
mug hand-painted and by the way how is
this not sticking to Democrats at all
like all of these problems cities that
we're about are controlled almost
exclusively by Democrats for all large
cities I know but for decades are people
not going hey I keep voting for these
people and they can't change anything
like if it's systemic they're a part of
the system the people that you put it on
as awaken are the system there is no
other system than that look a lot more
mayor and city council a nice yeah I
forget who said it but how did Donald
Trump end up being able to mess up only
Democrat run cities yeah he's like a
selective intestinal binder it only
binds to toxins not nutrients for the
detox
although inside baseball let's go to the
next clip and if the city doesn't feel
that it has to settle with you you're in
real trouble because civil suits against
cops are nearly impossible to win just
listen to a defense attorney explain one
reason that it was going to be difficult
for Michael Brown's family to suit the
Ferguson officer who killed him civilly
sure they could go after him civilly
the problem is he has qualified immunity
he's gonna say that I was acting within
the scope of my employment this is what
I was doing yeah and he is right about
that okay
so let's be clear with hundreds of
staffers over there at HBO and a
multi-million dollar salary himself his
source now I'll get the idea Jerry your
counsel we use here is a guy
[Laughter]
defense attorney who likely hasn't
practiced law in many years because he's
mostly spending his time being a guy
it's very hard to sue just listen to the
sky who are an picked to make my points
good and he's right and he's right
because otherwise some wrong guy like
post Krishna beetles know the reason it
was difficult for Mike Brown to sue
Darren Wilson's family the officer and
questions because unlike the hands up
don't shoot lie Mike Brown was
repeatedly punching the officer in the
head and reaching for his gun
specifically an officer by the way who
was known to serve under privileged
minority communities and had a stellar
track record yeah very different from
the George Floyd situation Mike Brown
which was the catalyst for all of this
it would be really hard to sue someone
for murder when you're trying to murder
them well this was in our montage I
think on Thursday where a guy was going
in to loot a store and a what a white
guy who owned the store who was holding
a shotgun at him this guy starts walking
toward the guy with the shotgun saying
hands up don't shoot like he's the
victim in this scenario Morrow on the
show all of the myths of these
protesters like firlock one kill on Omar
tweeted out the lady who was being
choked by the officer she was never
choked by the officer and then when you
see the full context the lady was
hitting the gearshift while the officer
was pulling over a fuse to provide ID
kept reaching into her purse when he
said origin of the person and then
finally when he's trying to get her to
the ground she goes but let's find a
name for it that's not how it works you
know whatever be arrested it's like
alright is this bag of methamphetamine
and this ak-47 yours and those underage
children in the back of your car they
come in from Honduras as sex slaves
sheriff damn it I'm gonna wait here for
we're gonna be here a while you want I'm
on base yeah yeah I'm safe oh my god
this is just ridiculous to me the hands
up don't shoot the mantra is a lie yeah
people by the way you've been right to
not allow an officer to search your
vehicle just to be clear if there's not
a valid warrant when you get and I think
this is important for people to know
there are videos on this you have the
right to not be detained unless you are
being charged do you have the right to
ask officers questions you should never
sit when the officer says do you know
why I pulled you over your answer should
always be no yes you tell me it's a
fishing question right learn that one
the hard way when I said broken
taillight he said speeding I said damn
it the taillights been fixed yes right
you know what else it makes it hard for
you to sue somebody is when he was
performing his job not just because that
shields him but because he was defending
his life right not all shootings or
crimes and in this case we talked about
he was defending his life and you make
that sound like it's a bad thing John
Oliver is making it sound like he was
murdered right it wasn't murdered when
you're beating somebody up and that's
why I understand your question does is
he stupid this this is one of those
mornings it's like someone who says
seven eight women get 70 cents on a
dollar
I don't think Barack Obama is stupid I
believe that Barack Obama has decided
the ends justify the means and is going
to perpetuate that lie in the American
public despite the fact that he's
probably read The Economist once yeah
there are people surrounding him all of
John Oliver's researchers are have the
same perspective they're not gonna send
him the sources that don't agree with
him right so obviously obviously he has
things hand selected before they get to
him so he can't reason through it right
but this is the weakest of all of their
arguments right of all the people right
because Trayvon Martin wasn't wasn't a
police officer that had any interaction
with him but this is the in my opinion
the weakest one yes like why do you Tim
he's pretty bad too because he was you
know he was he had his hood on in the
park and was aiming what looked like a
real gun yeah yeah exactly and they were
you know people he shot someone with a
toy gun listen it wasn't like a
translucent red Dollar Tree squirt gun
yeah it looked like a replica and it
wasn't like it was just sitting in his
backpack right retinic people with it
yeah wasn't some guy who was in a nerf
or nothing chimera
gun barrels let's go here to the by the
way we have Manny the art critic later
he's as strong opinions on postmodern
art so that later it let's move on in
that clip defunding the police
absolutely does not mean that we
eliminate all cops and just succumb to
the purge instead it's about moving away
from a narrow conception of public
safety that relies on policing and
punishment and investing in a
community's actual safety net things
like stable housing her mental health
services and community organizations ah
yeah stable housing again more crime or
less crime had a deal with a crime in
stable housing the projects oh yeah
that's right uni please how do you deal
with the crime in Baltimore Ferguson
where there was potential irreparable
economic damages why do you think that
people in those cities said we want the
police back in here stat because it's
necessary to protect people who are
actually trying to keep an economy alive
in these cities you don't base policy
around the people tearing down live in
economies your base policy around
protecting people who are actual
contributors in these neighborhoods
that's what most of these businesses are
often black owned and they have a very
different opinion and they don't get a
voice on CNN absolutely and what you
don't know Steven is that when police
are president that's what causes crime
so if there weren't police in these
communities there would be no Odia
utopia right it would just be like a
nice apartment building well yeah right
the problem is that they actually do
believe that people are inherently good
right take away the outer core right
yeah if you take away any outer
constraints everybody will be able to
live up to their full potential and be
able to creatively express themselves
but it's a Marxist lie it's this idea
that again the problem is Authority the
problem is power no actually the problem
is our hearts the problem is that we
hate each other right right the way that
we love evil weed and you know only it's
like every every year before this year
you know history yeah forever no it's
been three things and we can we can
barter it'd be fine and the problem with
authority how do we fix it by monumental
Authority in assembly right right how do
you enforce it yeah yeah how do you
enforce it these are not
feeding world view it cannot work and I
tell you what not only have you turned
more people racist which just terrifies
me within the ramifications ten years
down the line yeah but you've also
turned more people who are libertarian
into semi populist nationalist because I
will tell you this I'm someone who
obviously is espouse personal liberties
and defunding the police er dissolving a
police union sorry for a very long time
but now at this point I go I would have
never imagined myself saying send in the
United States Army yeah but when you
have to react to a city on fire you've
moved people like me to actually
trusting the authority of the government
to some degree because of social media
they're more dangerous sometimes than
even the United States government
because people who are killing over 20
Americans and cities and harming our
officers and demanding the total
defunding of police and City Council's
are actually complicit with it it makes
me go I guess we do need the feds to
step in I don't like this about myself
but it's it's the exact same reason a
lot of conservatives have adopted the
Social Security thing as being a
necessity necessary right necessary
thing because they see that in a lot of
ways churches families have all failed
to take care of their people right right
and so okay well I guess some some other
higher by the way are there people could
be could be black could be white blue
black could be tutor Bismarck yeah yeah
so do we really think that we're in a
position culturally where we can
actually take away all of our safety
nets that we've put in I don't think so
I think we should take away the safety
nuts but the safety nets are a symptom
of a larger cultural problem again that
starts with ourselves disagree the
safety nets have been working like a
charm nary a criticism of the social
safety nets you shouldn't mean totally
defunding the police take it from MPD
ones if this is the activist group by
the way that they're pushing for the
complete abolishment of Minneapolis
Police when we talk about abolition here
in Minneapolis we're not talking about
rebranding police or privatizing police
or community policing or any of the
reform tactics that could potentially be
used to undermine this work we're
talking about building a police free
future so what are you supposed to do in
this police free future let's say if
someone someone like a George Floyd who
broke in and jammed a pistol into a
pregnant woman's gut look what do you
if you're that woman today here let's
watch on CNN do you understand that the
word dismantle or police free also makes
some people nervous for instance what if
in the middle of the night my home is
broken into who do I call
yes I mean I hear that a lot here from a
lot of my music and I know in myself too
and I know that that comes from a place
of privilege because for those of us for
whom the system is working I think we
need to step back and imagine what it
would feel like to already live in that
reality we're calling the police may
mean more harm is done that's the city
council president just to be clear
that's not some random person how do you
take an extreme example to make a point
that's the person in charge of the
pledges invokes isn't that terrifying it
comes so my body my choice unless we're
talking about rape then it's rooms for
all yeah well if the system is not
working for you tear down the system I
guess that's the right idea does anyone
actually believe for a second that if a
black woman is being raped and calls the
police dead please show up in like huh
good job go get him tiger and walks out
even if you believe that what happened
with George Floyd is indicative of the
entire police force which I don't I do
think we have some bad police officers
hey Freddie means protect them and we
need to do something about it absolutely
that does not mean that police are not
answering calls in these neighbors
because keep in mind most of these
police live in these communities yeah
you know who gets most the most upset
about this law abiding citizens that
live in those communities that are like
why won't the police come and help me
right some of the worst places in
America in Los Angeles in New York and
Chicago and I named them because they
have some of the worst places in America
right Detroit cops just sometimes don't
go to certain areas at certain times
because it's not safe if you know who is
most harmed by it while we're talking
about all these gaps we're talking about
you know who will be most harmed by this
is black women yes
black women specifically black women
will be defenseless and helpless and I
want to see well first off I want black
women out there to armed themselves I
want black women to be able defend
themselves because police response time
isn't the same in the whole country I
want to read more stories of strong
black woman
shoots would be intruder and rapists
instead of black woman victim of
domestic
used like six 9s girlfriend of seven
years by the way right and unfortunately
we'd also do we also do have a community
that glorifies it when you look at a lot
of our culture and when you look at
hip-hop I was amazed I went down the
rabbit hole of charlemagne and the 6-9
guy six six 69 this guy this guy
committed sex acts with a minor on
videotape yep yeah eat his girlfriend
for seven years admitted to it joined a
gang put a hit on somebody to have the
guy shot and then snitched on the gang
so we got a plea bargain and then he was
sent to prison and he got out because of
coronavirus and his asthma condition
well who has the privilege in that
situation this guy obviously does
because he's famous and has asthma
asthma magnifying glass start a fire
well what about the black cops too I
mean when you when you make a call for
the police it's not like you're just
gonna get white cops every single time
you're gonna get black cops and there
are more blacks than there are black
people yeah so so can I can I check my
is this like a menu number in an
emergency can I say I would prefer black
police officers or Hispanic police
officers yeah that the privileged I like
my police officers a la race cart yes
sir what is your police force our whole
police system is family-style
also no Italian cops don't trust the
guineas this clearly isn't about
individual officers it's about a
structure built on systemic racism that
this country created intentionally and
now needs to dismantle intentionally and
replace with one that takes into account
the needs of the people that it actually
serves and this is gonna take sustained
pressure and attention over a long
period of time okay a couple of things
to get to here how funny would it be if
I get taken off YouTube for guinea well
you know listen if they banned me if it
comes along with banning rapists
migrants when they talk about serving
their community again many of these
officers are from these communities why
isn't anyone asking how we conserve
noble police officers yeah that's
something people may say mostly peaceful
protesters well I disagree but certainly
mostly peaceful officers right how about
we find out how we conserve cuz I'll
tell you what this is something that
challenge everybody to do out there and
I would like you to comment let me know
that if you've done this but I have been
just driving up the cup and again I
always make sure my hands I don't say
hands up don't shoot and reach for the
gun right now
hi officer you know and I said hey
listen thanks I appreciate you um I know
that it's a tough job right now
I had one officer choke up yeah if
everyone out there just does that and
listen there's a one out of ten shot
that you say it to a dick was it gives
me the right to do give swirlies and
that's a problem this is one thing I
really do what we're talking about the
marginalize we're talking about people
who've been stereo listen what about the
good black cop that David Dorn's out
there that really is the Forgotten hero
as far as John Oliver's final point it
really is that's what it's about
individual officers the nine unarmed
black victims from from last year that
talked about nine total fatally shot
unarmed black victims that represents
0.1 percent of all african-american
deaths in 2019 blacks are far more
likely in this country to be killed by
other black Americans than by any other
race it's not even close that is a
problem that we need to address and by
the way it doesn't address
creating more government housing if
people go into government housing
they're still being raped abused and
killed by other fellow black members of
that government housing project
it doesn't throwing money at it doesn't
solve the problem we see it with schools
in Detroit and we see it with
project housing we this isn't people
want to say you're being superficial you
don't wanna get to the root of the
problem well it seems to me the only the
only root of the problem that you see is
white people and more money please more
money please and we know that hasn't
worked period yeah well and you'll
you'll have willing and sympathetic
years on the Democratic side because
they know that if they just keep
promising you free stuff promising a
better tomorrow promising that it's
gonna get better but never actually
delivering you'll vote for them for the
rest of your lives right right it's the
it's the one thing that just again blows
my mind that the people that you elected
can't deliver for you and you keep
voting for them every single time and
you and I would agree we want better
training for police officers we want
more funding to go to programs that keep
people from getting into crime in the
first place but there are two sides to
this conversation right the police can
do a better job and every single
community in America can also do a
better job the black community can do a
better job with their kids their
families white community can do a better
job with our kids and our families
everybody why are we only talking about
one side of the issue right because you
didn't think if you just don't be a jerk
when a cop comes up to you most of the
time you're gonna be just fine if you
don't have an attitude when you say
officer you don't have the right to
search my car but if you like you do not
have the right to search my car get out
of here like what do you think the cop
is gonna show the same thing but added a
get out I did yeah to get out of here
part I didn't I was it was over I'm
convinced using in the national
conversation we talk about bad cops
right and we talk about peaceful
protesters yeah some people talk about
bad actors as they say rioters and
looters or as I describe them the
majority and we also talk about bad
white people and good white people but
there is no national conversation about
recognizing good cops specifically good
black cops and that does matter as we're
going to parse everybody into statistics
by race it's something that is
worthwhile discussing when you have a
higher percentage of police officers who
are black than the general population in
America why do we examine the granule
the intricacies and get granular as it
relates to race in every other facet
where there really isn't any kind of
consistency if we're talking about
unarmed black people shot versus unarmed
white people for talking about
government project housing we're talking
bout printable spending but it is
undeniably
in front of us that there is a higher
percentage of black officers than black
Americans if you want to ask the tough
questions how about you ask why those
black Americans have decided that the
best way to serve their community is to
join the police force and why don't get
they don't get a spot on your quadrant
you on CNN ok we're gonna talk about
Drew Brees here in a second but right
now YouTube thank you you must go piss
off it's mug club only